i want to follow up on asking about
legalizing guns because i hear you are
interested in that when you talk about
that are you like tim sometimes says
repeal the second amendment i think he's
not in our own section
not repeal the second amendment that's
the opposite of that yeah what do you
say repeal all gun laws and make
everything like what about nuclear
weapons repeal the nfa and abolish the
agency
how far do you take it with destructive
weaponry that you think people should be
legally allowed to possess
so well let's look to the purpose what
was the purpose of the constitution why
is the second amendment in there defense
well that's my opinion i think it's
there so that the government the
government doesn't have a monopoly on
force like it did in every other country
the people have the right to bear arms
in our country why is that it's so that
tyranny can't prevail in this country
look can i elaborate on that i hear that
a lot and i think we can go deeper on
that tyranny doesn't need to come
domestically can come from foreign
adversaries right we can be conquered or
we can be corrupted from within the
right of the people to bear arms means
that as they that famous apocryphal
saying there's a gun behind every blade
of grass yet invade in this country
at the same time
tyranny from within so to end's point
where do you draw the line right is it a
nuclear weapon what is it well first of
all let's let's acknowledge that
whatever the police have
to protect you when they get there you
should have until they get there okay so
anything any police department owns
should be fair game it whether you know
existing laws would ban it or not
i don't think that one person should be
able to take over a country they
shouldn't be one person shouldn't have a
weapon that
enables them to do that but the people
need to have sufficient weapons to throw
off tyranny and it can't be where like
99 agree that it's tyranny what about
cyber weapons
like the police has like hacking tools
and stuff
um
i don't think that applies to the second
amendment maybe not yet but i think
that's a there's a problem there there's
a problem there with the fourth
amendment
um are you saying that should people be
allowed to have them it's software it's
math
like i don't think you should ban it
there's no there's no actually a
software code
we need some clarification is it illegal
to possess
a malware or a virus is it illegal to
possess
i it is illegal to infect someone's
computer with a virus or malware but
it's illegal to simply have it because
if it's not well it's legal to have guns
but it's not legal just go and shoot
somebody right yeah i wonder what levels
of of tech the police are using right
now to spy on people i know they have
things where they can like listen
through walls and it doesn't matter what
the technology is if they're violating
the constitution this is the thing it's
timeless
it says they don't have a warrant the
the police should not be able to use
that technology whatever it is what's
that thing they got where they fly they
take planes and they have this box that
just takes all cell phone data and just
breaks it i forgot it's called
it's uh
the police have this technology so
whenever this big protest you'll see
like a plane fly overhead or they set up
mobile sell sites and they have a device
that just takes
everything all of your text messages all
of your phone calls everything they get
at all they had those uh at many of the
the the riots uh during 2020 and i don't
know if it's factual but i'd heard that
they had them on january 6th as well so
probably i i wouldn't be surprised if
the capital has them just placed
everywhere and they're constantly spying
on and monitoring everyone's cell phones
so the first part of your question you
say the police the the local police we
should be on par with the police what
about the military
so let's go back to the revolutionary
war because that's what was fresh in
their minds right when they wrote
wrote these uh articles and and then
later the constitution and the bill of
rights
you would need the people need to have
sufficient arms that let's say if 30 to
40 percent tim and i were talking about
this before the show if 30 to 40 could
agree that this was legitimate tyranny
that needed to be thrown off
they need to have sufficient power
without asking for extra permission it
should be right there and completely
available to them in their living room
in order to to affect the change and you
know joe biden he has that famous quote
where he's like if you want to take on
the government you need you know nuclear
weapons which is just not true that's
not true at all the crazy thing fighter
jets can't occupy street corners yeah
well also how did we lose afghanistan
right oh look what it wasn't because
they were a nuclear power right
the taliban building nuclear warheads
and nerves the problem would be like if
one percent of the population had
weapons that were so strong that they
could take over well right this is a
good idea 20 percent
i believe the second amendment protects
your right to own nuclear weapons
i believe an individual citizen in this
country has a right to own a nuclear
warhead but not a delivery device oh all
of it all of it i think what about
biological weapons
absolutely all of it
all of it
the con the second amendment does not
say the right to keep and bear arms will
not be infringed unless it can kill a
certain amount of people unless
it is a nuclear weapon unless it's a
biological weapon no no it says arms
arms arms arms nuclear arms biological
arms it says arms you got an issue with
that i can certainly understand why you
have to amend the constitution you
cannot just decide well we as a culture
hereby agree nuclear weapons are bad so
constitution doesn't matter anymore
no then you get together you have a
convention of states and you say we all
kind of agree it's not that you want
nuclear weapons to be legalized but
principally you think they should be
until we amend the constitution it
should not be hard to amend that or do
you principally think we should do you
principally think we should have well
hold on there a minute
um not necessarily but i do think it's
an interesting point you made thomas
that you know individuals should have
the ability to be at least on par with
the police i mean the police have a ton
of technology and weapons like lrads
acoustic weapons they have they've
experimented with light weapons and
other things that we don't have access
to they also have i'm pretty sure police
have select fire rifles which are
regulated under the nfa which we which
we have very difficult time getting but
if we're talking about let's let's say
we're gonna look at the purpose of the
second amendment and the that's why i
wanted to add that portion where it's
not just about domestic threats the idea
that you have armed militia ready and
waiting means that if a foreign
adversary comes in the local farmer is
able to come out and fight instead of
being disarmed well
what's happening though just in the
event that china lands u-boats on the
shores of california and they've got
high-grade military attack directed
energy weapons scud missiles whatever
well not scout missiles but cruise
missiles
what do the american people have to
resist that as they invade if they
invade and it could happen here can i
give you a case that's not that abstract
yeah and may certainly be in play
i think putin's calculus in in ukraine
is not whether it takes him four hours
or four days to establish air dominance
over that country because it's certainly
not more than four weeks right the
question for putin is once you do that
are are your soldiers willing to walk
out in the street
when somebody in a jogging suit or in
their pajamas some grandma in their
pajamas in an apartment building and
kiev
decides to blow your brains out and
you're just a soldier from russia that
wants to go home and be with his wife
and kids exactly that that ultimately is
the calculus that putin is making it's a
calculus anybody should make before you
go into afghanistan or something like
that do the people
who
who own the stuff are they willing is a
certain minority a certain group of them
willing to
defend it with their life if they're not
then it's not their country it won't it
won't be their country for long a
dictator will take over internally or
externally and what weapons do they have
are they willing to die for it and what
weaponry are they are they willing to
use that's a fantastic allegory thank
you well i think one way we can look at
this i know in georgia right now we
really want constitutional carry that's
something that's being pushed very hard
i believe that georgia senate is about
to pass it we're hoping that the house
will pass it and our governor will sign
it into law but talking about people
invading our country that's happening at
the southern border every single day and
you talk about farmers we had a house
freedom caucus we had a panel and we had
border patrol agents come in and many
different people and one of them was a
retired border patrol agent and he has a
family farm that is right there at the
border and he was telling the stories of
he he hates to leave his house because
he'll be leaving his wife and young
children there by themself and they
constantly have illegal aliens coming
right across their yard right by the
house they have them come up to the door
and he feels that he has to be there all
of the time to defend his wife and
children because he has guns and so when
you talk about a country being invaded
we are a country being invaded we're
being invaded non-stop every single day
at the southern border because the
current administration refuses to secure
our border and so it's it is a serious
issue the second amendment is so
important and and yeah i believe we have
to be able to have our i i think uh uh
that was an understatement not that
they're refusing to cure our borders but
they're aiding and abetting people who
are entering illegally yes the bite
administration has been taking these
people and putting them on planes and
flying them to other states when the
biggest stories the biggest scandals was
and republicans in tennessee got wind
that in the dead of night they were
bringing underage undocumented children
via military plane into their state
without telling them and then just
releasing them into communities i mean
look
that that is beyond just having a weak
border that is hey let's taxi you to
wherever you need to go and we'll help
you get there i mean that's that's
insane to me and it's worse than that
look at what we do with foreign aid
every year we send
just millions and billions of dollars in
foreign aid to these countries guatemala
central america mexico all of these
countries we send this money to these
basically these governments that aren't
taking care of their people and we don't
even know what they're doing with that
money we don't even demand an account i
would like to see an account of what are
you doing with this money personally i'd
like to cut it all off and keep all that
money back here at home but then these
countries these leaders these
governments who we're paying send their
people they just let them go and send
them up here to invade our country i
mean this is insanity and it should just
never be happening rather than us giving
foreign aid to other countries why
doesn't the federal reserve just print
the money form and leave us out of it
well what's the what's the difference
yeah why do we have to pass it through
our government just to make us feel good
about it it's still flooding uh the the
saturating by the way i will document it
and cut out the middle man by the way a
lot of those 1200 checks went to people
overseas who were not americans they
didn't have a green card oh i see
because then there's little to no
oversight because we have yet to audit
the federal reserve we haven't done that
yeah we do need we should
totally audit the thing so so let me ask
you some questions you're stripped of
your committees are you able to write up
bills and stuff what is that what does
that mean for you know oh yeah i can i
can write bills submit bills um
i've co-sponsored some of thomas
massey's bills he's co-sponsored some of
mine fire fouchy we are totally all
about getting rid of anthony fauci um no
i operate completely as all the other
members of congress i just don't have
have to be a republican that sits on a
useless committee because democrats are
fully in charge right now that's
actually it's been a great thing i think
i've had the advantage of learning more
and working harder on the outside being
without committees um in this congress
especially when republicans are in the
minority but the good news is i get
committees back the next time okay have
you uh have either of you
drafted legislation to either repeal the
nfa abolish the atf or audit the fed
abolish the atf you you did that one yes
yes
beautiful yes very good i've introduced
audit the fed every year that oh every
year yeah i should have known sponsored
it i'm going to make sure i'm a
co-sponsor and uh
does rand paul do that in the senate i
believe he's big on that isn't he oh
yeah yeah oh i'm on it i did oh i'm on
him and bernie were working on that
weren't they interestingly enough oh
bernie's had a change of heart bernie
was all for it when he was in the house
and a lot of these senators were for it
when they were in the house we've passed
it through the house and then it goes to
the senate and then people that
magically had this epiphany when they
got to the senate that we shouldn't
audit the fed yeah it's kind of like how
he had that magic epiphany that
millionaires weren't bad anymore once he
became one now it's just billionaires
right if you want to have a house you
can write a book write a good book it's
true you can do it by the way i got i
was getting when trump was was gonna
name uh betsy devos to be the secretary
of education i got swamped with phone
calls people were telling me not to vote
for and we had to explain i'm in the
house i'm not in the senate so
that clearly you know the education
system has failed you on this point but
what she knows about crt you know like
they said they the people said that
that's just an excuse we know you can do
something so i did i wrote a bill a one
sentence bill because my colleagues a
lot of them don't have a long attention
span it says that
and i've reintroduced it it says the
department of education shall terminate
on december 31st
20 22. and that's the entire bill so now
when they call up and they're mad or
when they were calling up and they were
mad i said well
you know
i've introduced a bill to eliminate her
job so you don't have to worry about it
because i don't think that the president
or his appointees should decide how or
what your children learn amen yeah amen
it's funny how when it's you know donald
trump they agree with you but then as
soon as you get a bite and they're like
well hold on there a minute i'm kind of
okay with it now my problem with repeat
with um ending the education department
is that it ends a lot of people's
livelihoods so a lot of people behind
the scenes are like oh f that we're
gonna we're gonna stop him but if you
can transmute the department into some
other useful tool or function same with
the federal reserve i don't just want to
cancel it i want to create a new
economic structure and then you know
port over but ian the other day you were
sort of making a point about automation
and how it's inevitable and we don't
want people to do jobs that aren't
useful and if the department of
education is unnecessary those people
should just be occupied necessarily
i've got those numbers there are 4 000
people at the department of education
none of them have written a book or
teach taught a class they make an
average of a hundred thousand dollars a
piece wow we could take that money
which and and send it to the states
where the states could collect it and it
doesn't have to go through federal hands
and they could hire more teachers
taxpayers imagine doing an actual job
yeah like a trade a real job building
houses and cleaning sewers and then
being a truck driver a truck driver i
think truck drivers do pretty much
podcasts
but but imagine that making cartoons
you're working hard
you're driving your truck long haul long
nights cross country away from your
family
and then some
bureaucrat in the department of
education is getting six figures to do
what and your taxes are paying for them
it's yours and it's the party of empathy
and compassion who cares about the
working class that is ensuring that this
will always be the state of affairs
they're for the worker i think for the
workers for example they would have it'd
free up 400 million which would
translate to i think eight million per
state is that what that comes out to for
teachers to hire teachers that could be
a a mass movement well well it should be
a mass movement yes yes but but is it
also possible that um you both could
just introduce more legislation to uh
terminate more departments within the
government i personally think we
shouldn't pass bills and create more
departments we need to get rid of
departments
the size of the federal government so
that is the biggest problem it's out of
control so i like where you're going
with this you know it's one sentence the
department education will terminate have
you considered that for any other
department cdc would be at the top of my
list oh yeah why is that
because they're counter to health policy
exactly like they have been they've not
just been a benign waste of money they
have been hurtful to health it's not
it's not economy versus health by solely
focusing on on the virus they have
neglected suicide diabetes uh
you know heart disease that was
something that also said but but is this
an issue we've been neglecting it's an
issue of government failure right is
there is there a private response that
would have been better i think the
department of justice is one we should
seriously look at they have weaponized
and gone after parents that are going to
school boards demanding uh about how
their children are being educated how
their children are being treated at
school the the department of justice has
completely gone way past their bounds
you guys ever see that movie with robin
williams
what was it called he's the comedian who
becomes president by accident or he went
he runs for office yeah what was that
what was that called we watched it and
it was it's kind of a weird movie
because it really feels like
it feels like propaganda almost it's you
know we had this period of the year 2006
where you know jon stewart was very
popular and people were like john
stewart should run for office with
stephen colbert or whatever and this
movie comes out where it turns out the
comedian realizes he shouldn't be
president and the people don't want a
populist leader they want experts who
know what to do and i watch that movie
i'm just i just find it so strange but
uh but but anyway if you're looking for
an analog to what's really going on
watch idiocracy yeah shortly but dietary
here's my point electrolytes we have
plants crave we have these tropes that
the people want a down-to-earth funny
guy to be
you know the the the president or the
leader and you end up with the trump and
i'm like i'm wondering if the people
would just accept politicians who are
like once i get in i'm gonna vote to
shut it all down that's all i'll do uh
you get your money back you figure out
what you want to do with it and then
we're gonna shut down all these
departments across the board they want a
plan they wanna they wanna dream they
want to
to just close their eyes and see the
world that you're envisioning i think
some people do some people do want that
yeah i mean i think
to be honest that's someone i would vote
for now maybe i'm a niche voter here but
one thing i really appreciate about both
of you is that you're actually talking
about reducing the size and scope of
government and terminating some of these
agencies and interestingly enough
whenever someone is conservative tries
to do that and tries to go back to the
way things were as a conservative is
supposed to they're called an extremist
all the establishment conservative is
supposed to do is either a try to
maintain
the size of the government and maintain
the institutions which were all set up
by big government leftists in years
prior and the moment anyone tries to do
more than that and reduce the size and
scope of government they're an extremist
can i explain the feedback mechanism
that causes that to happen in congress
please do so you get selected for
committees
based on it's almost like a beauty
pageant and the the lobbyists are the
judges
the lobbyists who have their interests
in front of those committees
and so you have to get cheerleaders on k
street who want you to be on that
committee and oversee their stuff so
you're already self-selected for
perpetuating their things so that's why
on the armed services committee there
even when republicans get in charge
they're not likely to repeal the vaccine
mandate because they are doing in large
part what the generals do when i was on
the science committee
nasa the people at nasa write those
bills and and send them over and say
this is what we want and the congressmen
are so busy and
can't understand most of it they rub or
stamp it and it rolls through and maybe
some of it goes to their district
because they were chosen to be on that
committee because they have something in
their district that that committee funds
and it's important to their constituents
so that once they get on they want to
keep funding it how do we solve this
national divorce
yeah but that always will result in a
civil war it shouldn't it doesn't have
to so just like a married couple that
decides that you know we can no longer
be married this is not working they
resolve the situation in a court right
they don't they don't actually go to war
and or they shouldn't try to kill each
other maybe some of them do i don't know
but they dissolve it they dissolve their
marriage in a court and so essentially
really what national divorce should look
like is it should go back to how our
nation is founded where state rights
were far more important than the federal
government and the federal government's
role should be reduced down to a very
small role and state rights should be so
strong and so that you know if you want
to live in a state where everyone has to
be vaccinated everyone has to wear three
masks at least three maybe four and then
you want to have a more communist style
state government
and crt is taught in the schools crt
absolutely and and all of these radical
things are what we call radical but they
may love it sounds like massachusetts or
california but they should be able to
have that and then if you're like like
kentucky or or georgia even or florida
you want to have a more conservative uh
pro traditional family values let's say
that you want to say no you you can
choose to be vaccinated or you can
choose to wear a mask and you want to
have a more free government you should
be able to have it and then there's no
interference the federal government's
not going to shrink itself so here
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you